freude das geht herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge hat ein tag
persönlicher koch und ihr habt
vielleicht dem titel gesehen ich habe
heute ein ganz ganz besonderen gast
und da kommt er auch schon nach so etwas
geht machte hinter dir auch nach sein
dass sie mir diesen tipp an dem entfalte
stacy gemütlich und wir sehen uns beim
essen wieder alles klar
er ist einfach so unglaublich was ich
mir von mir gewünscht habe ich mache
heute einen tick tock brad pitt so ein
bisschen in richtung von der praxis
kiffer die ich mal sturm wie gemacht
habe wir benötigen einige platten dieses
laden schneiden weg genauso
und das sieht man aktuell überall im
internet nicht nur auf twitter sondern
auch auf youtube instagram überall
dadurch dass man ihn so anschaut kann
man ihn nämlich jetzt einfach sagt zack
zack zusammenhalten und jedes viertel
einzeln belegen ich habe für ein für die
tomate für ein viertel abobo und dann
noch bacon und sandwich käse warum mache
ich einfach persönlicher kopf für mich
selbst weil ich schlecht im planen bin
aber das ist jetzt glücklich dass
trotzdem ganz gut für euch ich habe aber
besserung gelobt ich habe natürlich viel
geplant ist für ende des monats noch
eine kleine tour machen davon so leute
kommt ihrer zählt also und so van halst
vor ich habe hier eine kölnberg tomate
ich meine oben und unten ab drohen dann
verliere ich sie mal so strunk da oben
noch ein bisschen weg und daraus mache
jetzt einfach so eine kleine würzige ja
fast schon so einrichtung brust heften
und die halbe rhein papier gefallen seit
von pfeffer an ein kleiner drittel von
olivenöl beziehungsweise ich habe mir so
ein großer öl tatsächlich
durch und lassen es eine seite
marinieren und dann brauchen wir das ein
persönlicher kochrezept avocado die idee
ich dafür einfach mal gehört einfach
dazu
das heißt gegeben im becken rein
knusprig bild mache ich hier schnell die
akp die generell wenn ich nur für mich
sehr ich kaufe mach ich halt keine suche
aufwendigen rezepte oder sachen oder
sowas und glauben wir deutlich werde ich
auf jeden fall sehr kritisch bewerten
also nur weil ich jetzt heute für mich
selbst koche wird es nicht weniger
spannend weil ich werde mich in die
position von einem gast auf meinen alten
ein versetzen beziehungsweise max wird
das tun dann könnt ihr euch auf jeden
fall freuen weil es bleibt also auch
hier kommen natürlich jeder seite
pfeffer zum einsatz und dann habe ich
noch sauber trieben auch sehr wichtig
personen rappt finde ich persönlich ich
wollte eigentlich eine ganz normale
kaufen aber da ist sind kräuter dabei so
und wenn der berg nicht fertig ist neben
auch schon heraus und dann lege ich kurz
in die heiße pfanne in rap und lassen
ein bisschen weich werden
dadurch lässt sich jetzt besser falten
das reicht schon ganz kurz nur dann ist
es auch schon soweit heute hier ist
unser rap der ist jetzt gut lief war und
sein weil sonst kann der relativ leicht
zerbrechen wir nehmen ein wenig von
unserer avocadocreme man ein viertel
voll mit der avocado creme ein weiteres
viertel tomate das nächste bild ist das
ungesunde viertel und es kommt mit käse
und bacon das letzte viertel kommt prima
mir dann kann es auch schon losgehen
nummer 1 nummer 2 und nummer drei buben
hier ist unsere frühstücks tasche sieht
crazy nights aus wir belassen ist
natürlich nicht ganz dabei sondern geben
das ganze nochmal denen die fahne hinein
mit einem kleinen gewicht oben drauf so
dass der käse und schön an schmelzen
kann das ganze schön komprimiert wird
so jetzt ist auch schon weiter und wird
einen tick tock feldrapp und du das
gerne einfach mal den ersten bissen das
von dem ein bisschen auf sich wirken
lassen und dann sehen wir uns vielleicht
wenn die kamera aus gibt okay okay leute
jetzt gesehen die erste reaktion keine
ahnung was dieser mensch verbreitet
gesehen und papiere der teller leer
gefegt kommen wir zur bewertung also
erstmal zu dem sektor zum rap das ganze
hat also die größe von so einem fastfood
selbst darauf fand ich persönlich
eigentlich ganz cool dass er für ein
bisschen weniger essen will weil ich das
vielleicht dementsprechend fange ich
ehrlich gesagt dass das eine heiße
angelegenheit war was man aber ein
bisschen raus geschmeckt und
außenmärkten war dass der song klingt
gekauft war ich weiß du wolltest du das
nicht so aber nichtsdestotrotz haben
oder so wissen
diese stamme kräuter rausgeschickt beim
öl was ein bisschen der ähnliche sachen
islam besser aus als es geschmeckt hat
nichtsdestotrotz lassen sehr rege stift
ich würde dem ganzen eine 75 von 10
geben weil der becken bestimmt hat ein
paar andere sachen
aber ja 7,5 und 10 ich hoffe ein
bisschen mehr zufrieden
ja also würde ich dem ganzen auch hier
ist also letztlich besser machen kann ja
und ich habe auch wir sehen uns zum
mittagessen so leute da kann auch schon
zum mittagessen beziehungsweise zum
abend ist nicht erst nötig erklärte ich
nur zweimal am tag deshalb mache ich ja
was jetzt das mittagessen morgen das
abendessen es gibt von kempis channel
also von den professionellen koch für
die ich gekauft habe
das sagt andré soll
deswegen einfach gemacht haben ich habe
richtig bock darauf dass jetzt nicht
alles dafür da alles besorgt und wir
wägen los zunächst was ich hier mal eine
handvoll cherrytomaten runter wir sie
einfach mal übrigens selbst ball von max
sich nicht besser treffen können so
weiter geht es mit knoblauchzehen und
nur zwei stück dann würde das für seite
nämlich ein bisschen frischen rosmarin
dass ich mal so eine erste nacht auf
jeden fall schon und frischem thymian
fasnacht auch dann mit der wuchsrichtung
der blätter abziehen das macht heute
einfach so verschieben wir das ganze ein
bisschen zusammen und packen schnell
durch ich habe tatsächlich richtig weil
wie gesagt er sagte zweimal am tag ich
habe auch gar nicht so drastisch
hungergefühl aber ich merke das immer
wie es auf jeden fall die energie
gebrauchen kann
das dürfte reichen schreibt mir ist eine
kleine schüssel geben alles hinein so
schön sieht das dann außer eine prise
zucker brot ein wenig olivenöl
wir haben wir das ganze ein bisschen
ruhig vor der geruch genau wie er sich
das mit kevin gekocht habe es nicht so
gut
mein gott und den ganzen spaß mit 240
grad in den ofen
der teil das ganze system sind
karamellisieren und dünsten jetzt viele
gewürze und traum dann geht's weiter
linus 2
schalottenwürfel das ist zufrieden mit
mir sieht ähnlich aus wie das career
market also weiß ich nicht das ganze
sehr gut
dann können wir auch schon einen topf
auf den herd setzen so der topf wird
derzeit gibt zwar ein bisschen olivenöl
hinein und deren der top heißt wir
bereiten die noch in unseren mozzarella
vor dann zucken wir jetzt unseren
mozzarella hier so ein bisschen hinein
einfach schön so schönes stückchen von
hand nicht schneiden oder so ist ich auf
jeden fall fans hier aus wenn man das
ganze so macht und ich habe das gefühl
dass die oberfläche dadurch größer wird
das schneidet und dem marinieren das
jetzt dementsprechend ist das ein sehr
guter punkt beim agieren wir das ganze
klassisch mit ein bisschen salz und
pfeffer das müssen wir durch heben zu
lassen ist an der seite steht natürlich
ihr 400 milliliter wasser sind kochen um
gleich eine brühl ausmachen so ist es
jetzt auch soweit wir geben unsere
glocken hinein und die spitzen jetzt ein
bisschen an
vielleicht ist nur olivenöl die
verrotten drin weil sie so dass den
ganzen boden bedecken und bist ja so
sieht sehr schön aus riecht sehr gut die
charlotte sind jetzt schön classic jetzt
geben wir circa 200 gramm die sache bald
dazu einfach ohne wasser erst mal ist
ein risotto reis schwitzen wir jetzt so
ein bisschen mit an und er wird ihr
schon so richtig schön classic dass das
ziel gesetzt hier und jetzt lassen wir
das ganze mit weißwein ab den weißwein
lassen wir komplett verkaufen
darauf habe ich jetzt die 400 milliliter
brühe geschüttet und jetzt kommt dazu
nachfahren nehmen davon so ein paar fans
nicht zu viel saft uns sehr intensiv und
geben das mit rein zu rechnen so sieht
das ganze langer zeit aus wir geben
jetzt einen guten stich butter hinein
wenn ich noch ein bisschen auf circa 50
gramm und die schmelzen jetzt da drin
und rühren sie ein
es liegt schon sehr schloss sich aus die
leute die kevins video geschaut haben
bisschen bescheid und dann geben wir so
eine gute handhabe seien noch dafür
würden den ebenfalls ein bisschen salz
noch dann schmecke ich das ganze auch
schon ab bisschen viel biss hatten
bleibt also nur kurz aber unfassbar
lecker schon so leute das ganze sieht
super aus zu nehmen wir uns ja auch
draußen löffel und führen dass hierüber
und dann eben jetzt das ganze und
garnieren ist dann müssen wir das geht
nicht anders diese lücken
mit marinierten mozzarella wenn euch
nochmal ganz gut aus das ist so gerupft
ist meiner meinung nach dann kommt
darüber ein wenig rucola dann noch
obendrauf parmesan vorbild mir das ganze
optisch abzurunden
[Musik]
doch dann kommen wir auch mal zum mittag
die also ich muss sagen es sieht sehr
selten aus werden wir die kirschtomaten
dürfte monsterwelle rock oder obendrauf
gehobeltem parmesan ich will gar nicht
eingehen sondern ich probiere direkt bei
die erste gabe was dir schmecken
ich würde sagen wir so dass gleich
wieder würde ich auch sagen wir sehen
uns bald wieder einen muss wirklich
sagen ja es ist genauso lecker wie
damals bei kevin das will was heißen
die tomaten bringen das süße und
fruchtigkeit rein das sagt haben wir
sollten sich ist einfach so eine super
vollmundige runde sache für mich ist und
war das auch mit cvc kann ich nicht viel
zu sagen einfach eine kleine komposition
probst gehen auch erkennen ja was soll
ich dazu sagen ich bin sehr gespannt was
das für das abitur vorbereitet hast
kannst du sein
wir legen los mit dem abend ist und wir
kommen zur letzten mahlzeit ich brauchte
für meine küchenmaschine die würde man
braucht nicht unbedingt man kann es
natürlich auch von hand machen soll ich
brauche nur die kleine schüssel ich
mache das ja nur für mich wir machen
übrigens flammkuchen und ich starte mit
120 milliliter warmen wasser sodass gehe
ich in die rührschüssel dazu gibt es
schon einen halben teelöffel trockenhefe
böse die trockenhefe im wasser auf kommt
man mit franz kleine prise zucker dazu
dann ein guter esslöffel olivenöl
hier ist das jugend grund die aufnahme
abgestürzt ich habe den teig vom haken
wird kratzt auf die arbeitsfläche
gegeben eine kugel daraus geformt sie in
die schüssel gegeben und für 20 minuten
in den ofen bei eingeschalteter lampe
zum gehen gegeben
ich kümmere mich um den verlag vom
flammkuchen ich schneide hier eine tiefe
auf ich mache das ganze ganz klassisch
also elsässer art zwiebeln speck
dann schnappe ich mir hier einen sicher
creme fraiche ganze würzen mit salz
pfeffer und an benötigen nur noch ein
paar speckwürfel dann bereitet ihr schon
mal fürs aus wollen die arbeitsfläche
vor
da gibt jetzt zwei schlanken
daran hat man später auch noch ein so
sieht der spaß aus bisschen klebrig ist
aber nicht dass ich mich mit ein
bisschen mehr gegeben nächste oder dann
halten wir den spaß geben gegen wen ich
brauche ein bisschen mehl und schüssel
oder anfangen doch schon an den
flammkuchen auszurollen
wenn eine schöne form hat wenn wir auch
schon her gehen und unser pizza blech
mail wechsel mail and spielt eine
entscheidende rolle hier viel mehr drauf
er bewegt sich doch dann habe auch schon
gelegen ist fresh wichtig bei einem
flammkuchen ist dass der pizza stein
schön heiß ist und die luft die von
außen dran kommt nicht so super heiß ist
und wie ihr merkt ich persönlich finde
klang kuchen geht wirklich wie jeder
tages und nachtzeit around here we go
ist schön wackelig auf dem blech das
heißt wir geben jetzt draußen laufen
also da man mit dem pfannkuchen und die
reklame runter
[Musik]
so dann ist es auch schon so weit wir
kommen zum abendessen was sagst du wie
sieht das ganze aus hama also finde ich
würde auch sagen also ich bin sehr
zufrieden mit meiner leistung und nimmt
gerne mal den ersten bist ok dann sehen
wir uns gleich wieder zu bewerten dürfen
sehen ich habe alles komplett
aufgegessen ja ich muss sagen es war
sehr sehr nice man trägt ja auf
weihnachtsmärkten so auch flammkuchen
dabei auf jeden fall konkurrenzfähig ist
das war aber nicht der beste sprint den
ich je trainiert habe
ich glaube du kannst und ein bisschen
besser dementsprechend gebe ich den
ganzen hier eine 8 1
für mich ist das ein wahrhaft einheit
bei neuen werten richtig perfekt ist
eine c
hast du auch schon mal hinbekommen das
waren 8 dementsprechend hätten wir das
ganze ding hier
vielen dank fürs dabeisein und was ein
sehr angenehmer gabst du hast dich
kommt's noch nie gerichtet war mit ihr
zu drehen nächste woche sonntag um 14
uhr haben wir wieder einen normalen gas
macht es gut bis dahin und dies alles
klar
[Musik]